This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is part two of the 2019-2020 mini-stories episodes, where I interview the staff about their favorite little stories from the built world that don't quite fill out an entire episode for whatever reason, but they are cool 99PI stories nonetheless. We have centuries old bonds, standard tunings mandated by international treaty, abandoned mansions, and secret babies. If you ever need a conversation starter, these mini stories are our gift to you. Stay with us. First is producer Joe Rosenberg. Okay, so Joe, what do you have for me?
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是2019-2020迷你故事系列的第二部分，在这期节目中，我采访了我们的工作人员，让他们讲述他们最喜欢的、关于人造世界的那些小故事。不知出于什么原因，这些故事可能不足以撑起整整一期节目，但它们依然是精彩的99PI故事。我们有历时几个世纪的债券、由国际条约规定的标准音高、废弃的豪宅以及秘密婴儿。如果你需要一个聊天的话题，这些迷你故事就是我们送给你的礼物。请继续收听。首先是制片人乔·罗森伯格。好的，乔，你给我带来了什么？
What I have for you, Roman, is a story that I have been sitting on for quite some time. Mm-hmm. You know, it's one of those planet money pitches that I never sent to planet money. I got a drawer full. Yeah. And it actually starts, I rather, my familiarity with it starts about five years ago when I was reading the news and I came across this weird little AP wire service item. Yeah, weird AP wire service items are especially. Yeah, exactly. And it was about this announcement in Britain by George Osborne, the then chancellor of the exchequer in the UK, that Britain was finally going to finish paying off its bonds from World War One.
罗曼，我给你带来的是一个我压了很久的故事。嗯哼。你知道，这是一个我从未投给“金钱星球”的“金钱星球”选题。我抽屉里有一大堆。是的。它的开端其实——或者说，我对它的熟悉大约始于五年前，当时我在看新闻，偶然看到了美联社的一条奇怪的小快讯。没错，美联社的奇怪快讯总是特别引人注目。对，没错。那是关于英国时任财政大臣乔治·奥斯本在英国发布的一项公告，称英国终于要还清第一次世界大战的债券了。
Like a hundred years ago, World War One, not World War Two, World War One. Yes, bonds from the war to end all. That's right. Still, counting the cost of the Great War, Britain is only now redeeming most of the remaining bonds raised to pay for World War I, 100 years after it started. Britain has remembered its debt to the fallen. Another country is set to repay its financial debt. The government will pay off more than $300 million
就像一百年前，第一次世界大战，不是第二次世界大战，是一战。是的，那场终结所有战争的战争的债券。没错。时至今日，仍在计算第一次世界大战的代价，在第一次世界大战爆发100年后，英国才刚刚开始赎回为支付一战而发行的绝大部分剩余债券。英国没有忘记对阵亡者的债务。另一个国家准备偿还其金融债务。政府将偿还超过3亿美元
worth of those bonds in February. And I was like, how is it possible that it's only now paid off its bonds from World War War? Because I mean, I know it must have been expensive and obviously Britain issued a lot of bonds to pay for it. But I think you're, you know, Britain, one of the wealthiest countries in the world, must have paid off those bonds like a long time ago. Yeah.
在二月份赎回这些价值的债券。当时我就想，怎么可能直到现在才还清第一次世界大战的债券呢？因为我的意思是，我知道这肯定花了很多钱，而且显而易见，英国发行了大量债券来支付这笔费用。但我想你会觉得，你知道的，英国作为世界上最富有的国家之一，肯定在很久以前就把那些债券还清了。是的。
Just so I make sure I'm up to speed. A bond generally is like when the government needs funds for something and they don't have enough cash on hand, so they go to the populace essentially and they say, buy this bond for X amount of money and then over a course of 10, 20, 30 years, we will pay you back that amount of money plus a little bit of interest.
为了确保我跟上了节奏。债券大致上就是当政府需要资金来做某事，而手头又没有足够的现金时，他们基本上就会去找民众，然后他们说：买下这笔价值X金额的债券，然后在10年、20年、30年的时间里，我们会把这笔钱连同一点利息一起还给你。
And this is guaranteed by the government, so it's a really, really safe investment. Right. And after like max 30 years, usually the bond matures, that's the term at which point the government has redeemed the bond. So they paid back everything and the interest in 30 years time. Correct. And they are no longer in your debt. Right. But these World War One bonds weren't redeemed until they were 95 years old. So that seemed way too long for a bond. Yeah, no, it's crazy. But then it got weirder because it turned out World Bar One
而且这是由政府担保的，所以这是一笔非常非常安全的投资。没错。而且在最多30年左右之后，通常债券就会到期，这就是那个期限，在这个时间点政府已经赎回了债券。所以在30年的时间里，他们已经还清了所有本金和利息。没错。而且他们不再欠你的债了。没错。但这些一战债券直到95岁高龄才被赎回。所以这对于一战债券来说显得时间太长了。是的，不，这太疯狂了。但接下来事情变得更诡异了，因为事实证明，一战
was just like the most well-known thing the British government wasn't done paying off. There were actually older bonds from their books that they announced they were also redeeming as part of this package, including bonds from, wait for it, the Crimean War. A relief effort for the Irish potato famine, the slavery abolition act, the Napoleonic war. Goodness gracious.
只是英国政府尚未还清的最著名的一项。他们的账面上实际上还有更古老的债券，他们宣布也将作为这揽子计划的一部分进行赎回，其中包括来自——你猜怎么着——克里米亚战争的债券。为爱尔兰大饥荒提供的救济工作，废除奴隶制法案，拿破仑战争。天哪。
And even that wasn't the oldest of the debts, because after making the announcement about World War I, George Osborne, the chancellor of the ex-checker, must have felt that he was on a roll, because he then sent out a tweet, which just might be the most anachronistic tweet that you'll ever see check this out Okay, it says will redeem 218 million pounds of debts incurred Because of the South Sea bubble another financial crisis or cleanup after what was the South Sea bubble?
甚至连这都不是最古老的债务，因为在宣布了一战的消息后，财政大臣乔治·奥斯本一定觉得自己状态正佳，因为他随后发了一条推特，这可能是有史以来最不合时宜的一条推特，来看看这个。好吧，上面说将赎回价值2.18亿英镑的债务，这些债务是因南海泡沫事件而产生的——又是一场金融危机——或者是南海泡沫之后的清理工作？
What is he talking about so what he's referring to there are bonds from a government bailout of investors who were ruined by the infamous South Sea China bubble in 1720. Oh, of course, how could I forget? The South Sea China bubble is 1720. Right. Of course. Well, I mean, apparently, obviously, like these bondholders who were still getting paid back by the UK government 300 years later, they had not forgotten, they were still expecting their money. That is incredible, 300 years of bonds, how is that possible? So it turns out what is going on and the reason there were these old, old debts, is that all these were examples of a very rare type of bond called a perpetual bond. So how does a perpetual bond work?
他在说什么？所以他提到的是政府对投资者的救助债券，这些投资者在1720年声名狼藉的南海泡沫事件中破产了。哦，当然，我怎么会忘呢？南海中国泡沫事件发生在1720年。没错。当然。好吧，我的意思是，显然，这些债券持有人在300年后仍然在从英国政府那里领回资金，他们并没有忘记，他们仍然在期待他们的钱。这太不可思议了，300年的债券，这怎么可能？所以事实证明，发生了什么以及存在这些陈年旧债的原因是，所有这些都是一种非常罕见的债券的例子，叫做永久债券。那么永久债券是如何运作的呢？
Okay, so a perpetual bond is quite simply a bond that never matures. It promises that instead of paying you back your principal plus interest in full after say 30 years, the government will just keep the principal. And instead they'll pay you your children and your children's children's children's children. A small amount of interest every year for basically all eternity or at least until they decide to redeem the bond, which means they finally decide to pay you back the principle, which is what the British finally did with 1200 or so perpetual bond holders in 2014. Wow. So when did they make a perpetual bond?
好吧，所以永久债券非常简单，就是一种永不到期的债券。它承诺，政府不会在比如30年以后一次性全额偿还你的本金加利息，而是会保留本金。取而代之的是，他们会付给你、你的孩子、你孩子的孩子们的孩子们一笔小额利息，基本上是直到永远，或者至少直到他们决定赎回债券，这意味着他们最终决定把本金还给你，这正是英国人在2014年对大约1200名永久债券持有人所做的事情。哇。那么他们是什么时候发行永久债券的呢？
I mean, maybe your better question is, why did they do it in the first place? Because it seems like a really bad idea to borrow money this way. What did this idea come from? The answer is actually that in some ways, in the beginning, most bonds were perpetual bonds. Before there were even bonds, all borrowing, there was just a process through which you would rent money. You would rent capital.
我的意思是，也许你更好的问题是，他们当初为什么要这样做？因为以这种方式借钱似乎是个非常糟糕的主意。这个想法是从哪里来的？答案其实是，在某些方面，在最初的时候，大多数债券都是永久债券。甚至在有债券之前，所有的借贷都只是一个租赁金钱的过程。你在租赁资本。
So this is a Geert Ruinhurst. He's a professor of finance at Yale. And Geert says that if you go back to the Middle Ages, you have to imagine an economy where actually kind of like today, renting is really popular. You might pay a small amount of money every month to rent a field or an oxen or a house. And just as you would rent a house for an unspecified amount of time, you would rent money for unspecified amounts of time. So in a private arrangements between two parties, it is always easy to say, I'm going to rent it for some
这位是吉尔·雷因霍斯特。他是耶鲁大学的金融学教授。吉尔说，如果你回到中世纪，你必须想象这样一种经济：实际上有点像今天，租赁非常受欢迎。你可能会每个月支付一小笔钱来租一块地、一头公牛或一栋房子。正如你会租一套房子不限定具体时间一样，你也会租借金钱不限定具体时间。因此，在两方之间的私人安排中，说“我要租借它一段不确定的时间，你给我打电话或者我给你打电话，贷款就此结束”总是很容易的。
unspecified time and you call me or I call you and it'll be the end of the loan. Right. So just the way that you rent an apartment and you give the apartment back when you're done renting it, you could do the same thing with money. Okay. So if you needed 50 gold coins and I were your creditor, I'd basically say to you, look, I'll give you 50 gold coins now and you can keep them as long as you want, just as long as you promise to pay me at least two gold coins a month indefinitely until you give me the original 50 coins back. Exactly.
没错。所以就像你租了一间公寓，在你租完后把公寓还回去一样，你也可以对金钱做同样的事情。好吧。所以如果你需要50枚金币，而我是你的债权人，我基本上会对你说：“听着，我现在给你50枚金币，只要你答应至少每个月付给我两枚金币，无限期地付下去，直到你把最初的50枚金币还给我为止，你想留多久就留多久。”完全正确。
Okay, that makes sense. So if that was the standard that the early type of loaning was perpetual loans, why aren't there more perpetual loans being paid out till to this day? Right. That's a good question. And it turns out that there were a few problems with perpetual loans. But the biggest might simply be that when it came to bonds issued by governments and companies, these types of bonds carry a lot of risk with them because governments and companies collapse
好吧，这说得通。所以，如果早期贷款的标准类型是永久贷款，为什么直到今天没有更多的永久贷款被偿付呢？没错。这是个好问题。事实证明，永久贷款存在一些问题。但其中最大的问题可能仅仅在于，当涉及到政府和公司发行的债券时，这些类型的债券伴随着巨大的风险，因为政府和公司倒闭
all the time at which point not only do payments stop But you're also not going to be getting your principal back like ever and Gert says this happened all the time So there were bonds issued by France before the French Revolution and by Russia before the Russian Revolution You know Spain defaulted on its debt like three times and so most perpetual bonds are now just lost a history So is the South Sea China bubble from 1720 is that the oldest perpetual bond are there even older ones out there? Actually their car older ones and Geert or rather Yale owns one of them Cool. Yeah, so Geert is the deputy director of an academic research group at Yoke
是常有的事，在那时不仅付款会停止，而且你也不会拿回你的本金——永远不会。吉尔说这种情况经常发生。因此，法国在大革命前、俄罗斯在革命前都发行过债券，你知道的，西班牙曾三次债务违约，所以绝大多数永久债券现在都已湮没在历史中。那么1720年的南海中国泡沫是史上最古老的永久债券吗？还有更古老的债券存在吗？其实还有更古老的，吉尔——或者说耶鲁拥有其中之一。酷。
called the Center for International Finance. And one of the things they do is engage in something called scrupophily, which sounds like an ancient skin wasting disease. But you know, all it means is that they collect and curate financial instruments from various places and times in history. And one of the most interesting contracts in our collection is the very old Dutch bond issued by a Dutch water authority in 1648, which pays interest as of today. So 1648, so this is a bond that's been actively paid back since 1648. Yes, and in fact all of the oldest known perpetual bonds, I think there's fewer than like half a dozen of them, are from this single Dutch waterboard. Okay.
是的，所以吉尔是耶鲁大学一个名为国际金融中心的学术研究小组的副主任。他们所做的事情之一就是参与一项名为“纸币集藏学”（scripophily）的东西，这听起来像是一种古老的皮肤消耗性疾病。但你知道的，它所代表的全部含义就是他们收集并策展历史上不同地方和时期的金融工具。我们收藏中最有趣的契约之一，是荷兰一个水务局在1648年发行的非常古老的荷兰债券，它从今天起还在支付利息。所以是1648年，所以这是一张自1648年以来一直在积极偿还的债券？是的，事实上，所有已知最古老的永久债券——我想数量还不到半打——都来自这单个荷兰水务局。好吧。
And the reason is because this waterboard is basically this regional entity, which for hundreds of years has been in charge of maintaining all of the dams and levies and digs, you know, in a given corner of the Netherlands. And you know, that's a good business to be in. It's really stable. To Dutch water authorities, they never go to war and they have the power of taxation. So they have been good borrowers. Right. And also there's a strong incentive for those institutions just to survive because
原因在于这个水务局基本上是一个区域性实体，几百年来，它一直负责维护荷兰某个角落的所有大坝、堤防和拦河坝。你知道的，这是一个很好的行业。它非常稳定。对于荷兰水务局来说，他们从不打仗，并且拥有征税权。所以他们一直都是优秀的借款人。没错。而且这些机构本身也有着强烈的生存动机，因为
people need them in order to not drown basically. That's right. Yeah. Which will become even more pertinent going forward. It's super cool. I actually also have a photo of it. Do you like to see it? Absolutely. Okay. If you pick up this book to your right, go to the flag page.
人们需要它们，基本上是为了不被淹死。没错。是的。这一点在未来将变得更加贴切。这太酷了。我实际上也有一张它的照片。你想看吗？当然。好吧。如果你拿起右手边的这本书，翻到国旗那一页。
This is a book geared and a colleague edited called The Origin of Value, which is about various financial instruments throughout the ages. There's a chapter all about this bond. And so you can see the front on the back of it here. Wow. Well, it's like, it's just a bunch of script. Like it doesn't look like designed the way I think of a bond looking with all the filigree
这是一本由吉尔和一位同事共同编辑的书，名为《价值的起源》，讲的是各个时代的各种金融工具。其中有一个章节专门讲述这张债券。所以你可以在这里看到它的正面和背面。哇。嗯，它就像是一堆手写稿。它看起来不像我想象的那样有精美设计的花边
and cool stuff about a bond. It's really basic. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Although what you will see at the center of the front page of the bond There are like there is the small print, you know, it's laying out the terms Okay, and in Dutch that even Gert says he has struggle reading this old Dutch, but basically it says and I'm gonna Bosh all of these names
和关于债券的酷炫东西。它非常基础。是的，是的，是的。尽管你在债券头版正中央会看到的是，有一些小字，你知道的，它列出了条款。好吧。用荷兰语写的，甚至吉尔都说他读这种古老荷兰语有些吃力，但基本上它是说——我要把这些名字全念砸了——
Johan von Hugenhook. That's the representative of the water board Acknowledges to have received from mr. Nicholas the major 1,000 careless guilders of 20 stoivos apiece. And does it say what those 100 careless guilders were for? Yes, actually does. It was for a new cribbing in the town of Humswick. And a cribbing apparently was a kind of pier that was placed in the bend of a river.
约翰·冯·胡根胡克。那是水务局的代表，确认已从尼古拉斯·梅杰先生那里收到了1000荷兰盾，每枚20斯蒂弗（stiver）。上面有没有说这100荷兰盾是用来做什么的？是的，实际上有。它是为了修筑亨斯威克镇的一处新护岸。显然，护岸是一种放置在河湾处的防波堤。
And the pylons of the pier would help prevent the bend in the river from shifting and meandering. Okay. So it just kind of keeps the river in place. Yeah. And don't get me started on meandering this panel or session, as you know. And so, and it's what is a what are stifers? I have absolutely no idea. Okay. But the bond also acknowledges that they owe an amount of 5% a year to Mr. Dmitriot, his heirsirs or other rightful persons, which means this bond is transferable either as a gift or by sale to anyone else. Right. The other thing I noticed about this is that there's all these notes and annotations
防波堤的桩柱可以帮助防止河湾发生位移和曲折。好吧。所以它有点像是把河流固定在原地。是的。别让我开始吐槽这个小组或会议上的河流曲折问题，如你所知。那么，什么是斯蒂弗？我完全不知道。好吧。但债券也确认他们每年欠米特里奥特先生、他的继承人或其他合法权利人5%的金额，这意味着这张债券可以通过赠送或出售的方式转让给其他人。没错。我注意到的另一件事是，四周到处都是各种笔记和批注。
all around the corners. I mean, it looks like it's been annotated essentially. Is this the sale and transfer, is that what that's all about? Those notations are a record of every single time someone has collected on the bond. And how much was paid out and when it was paid out. Oh, okay, cool. So it really is a living document which has been written on continuously throughout its 400 year history. It's like a blockchain. Yeah, exactly what it's like.
我的意思是，它基本上看起来像是被作了批注。这是买卖和转让吗，这都是关于什么的？这些批注记录了每一次有人凭此债券兑现的情况。以及支付了多少金额以及是何时支付的。哦，好吧，酷。所以它确实是一份生动的文献，在其400年的历史中一直在不断地被书写。这就像区块链一样。是的，它就像那个样子。
Even to the point where actually they know how much to pay out because they see all the previous notations so they know how much back interest they owe you. Wow. And you can actually see, they actually ran out of rooms. If you go to the next page of the book, starting in the 1940s, they added this thing, which is called an allonge, or sometimes a talon, which is basically like an extra bit of paper with the seal of the waterboard that continues this tradition of notating every payout. So I can see all the notations it goes across it looks like it goes all the way to 2003 on here it's really diligent. Oh no yeah and
甚至到了这样的地步：实际上他们知道该支付多少钱，因为他们看到了以前所有的批注，所以他们知道欠你多少背水利息。哇。你实际上可以看到，他们真的写不下去了。如果你翻到书的下一页，从20世纪40年代开始，他们添加了这样一个东西，叫做附加页（allonge），有时也叫副券（talon），它基本上就像是一张带有水务局印章的额外纸张，延续了记录每一次支付的传统。所以我可以看到所有的批注，它横跨过去，上面显示一直延续到2003年，这真的很勤勉。哦，不，是的，而且
one thing I love is that you can see the handwriting of the receiving clerk at the water board getting more and more modern and kind of less and less elegant as the world got more modern. So do we know these people who clutter this bond like is that written down here on who bared this bond? No, we actually don't, but Gert says that's kind of the point. This is a bearer bond. I mean, if you're the person holding it, you're the person they have to pay, it doesn't matter who you are. That's a unique aspect of a bearer bond. There doesn't need to be a record of who owns it. The bond itself is the ID.
我最喜欢的一点是，你可以看到水务局收款职员的笔迹变得越来越现代，随着世界变得越来越现代，字迹也变得越来越不那么优雅。那么我们认识这些在这张债券上乱涂乱画的人吗？是谁持有这张债券，上面有写吗？不，我们实际上并不知道，但吉尔说这正是关键所在。这是一张无记名债券。我的意思是，如果你是拿着它的人，你就是他们必须付款的人，你是谁并不重要。这是无记名债券的一个独特之处。不需要有谁拥有它的记录。债券本身就是身份证。
So you actually have to take this piece of paper and go to Holland to collect the money for it. Yes, precisely. That is the catch. Anyone can present this bond and collect their money, sort of no questions asked, right? Almost like it is money. But you have to physically present it to the registrar at the Water Board office. That's what all these notations are really notating.
所以你实际上必须拿着这张纸去荷兰才能领到钱？是的，准确地说。这就是窍门所在。任何人都可以出示这张债券并领取他们的钱，基本上可以说是“无需多问”，对吧？几乎就像它就是钱一样。但你必须亲自把它呈交给水务局办公室的登记员。这就是所有这些批注真正记录的内容。
Someone showed up. To keep it alive, the bond itself needed to travel in person with a bearer, at least once in a generation. So this is Tim Young. He's the curator of modern books and manuscripts at the Yale Bynarchy Library, which is where the bond currently lives. And he is the most recent bearer of the bond. He actually traveled all the way to Holland from New Haven to collect on it.
有人现身了。为了保持它的生命力，债券本身需要由一个持有人亲自携带，至少每一代人一次。这位是蒂姆·杨。他是耶鲁大学拜尼克图书馆的现代书籍和手稿馆长，这张债券目前就保存在那里。他是这张债券最近的持有人。他实际上从纽黑文一路旅行到荷兰去兑现它。
He was the first person to do that since Gear Dequired it. The way I picture this is that there's this old Dutch building from the 17th century, just sitting there. And an old man has been waiting for centuries. For sure, let's try that. A person to bear the bond in a clerk's suit, and I don't even know what. A scrivener. Exactly.
我是这样想象的：有一座来自17世纪的古老荷兰建筑，就那么静静地立在那里。一个老人已经等了几个世纪。当然，让我们试着想象一下。一个穿着职员服装的持券人，我甚至不知道该怎么称呼。一个书吏。没错。
Would be sitting there. It's a lit by a candle. He has a quill pen and he makes a notation and he hands him some money from an old tale or something and maybe it's in gold medallions or a script that is also 400 years old. Is this what it is? You nailed it, you nailed it on that.
会坐在那里。烛光照明。他拿着一支鹅毛笔，做了一个批注，从一个旧抽屉里拿出了几钱，也许是金质奖章，或者是同样有400年历史的手稿。是这样的吗？你猜对了，你完全猜中了。
No, actually, like what you said, it's all kind of like half true. Okay. When I showed up at this waterboard bond, it was a little town called Hootin. So my brother and I walked about, you know, half a mile down the street and found this very lovely building and knocked on the door.
不，实际上，就像你说的，这一切都有点半真半假。好吧。当我带着这个水务局债券出现时，那是在一个叫乌滕的小镇。所以我和我弟弟沿着街道走了大约半英里，找到了这座非常漂亮的建筑，并敲了敲门。
And I said, hi, I have my waterboard bond and go, oh yes, we're expecting you. And then we went to a conference table and they literally gave me a gigantic paper check like you see on TV. What did they do that? Well, so full disclosure, they actually had a Dutch television crew waiting for him. You were doing this a little bit.
我说，你好，我有我的水务局债券。他们说：哦，是的，我们正等着你呢。然后我们走到一张会议桌旁，他们真的给了我一张你在电视上看到的那种巨大的纸质支票。他们为什么那样做？好吧，坦白说，他们实际上安排了一个荷兰电视摄制组在等他。你当时是在做一点表演。
I mean, this was obviously a good PR for the waterboard and for Yale. They weren't going to let this moment go to waste. And then they gave me a real check, a small check that's to bring back to New Haven. But then they said, oh, let's actually go see the pier. So what is he talking about the pier? So the public work that this bond funded is still there. It's still staying. Oh, hey, it is. Okay. Yeah. And it's still regulating river flow, which just might be my favorite aspect of this whole story. Wow. Kind of a a real life human thing that was achieved by this bond. Yeah.
我的意思是，这显然对水务局和耶鲁大学来说都是很好的公关。他们不会让这个时刻白白浪费。然后他们给了我一张真正的支票，一张带回纽黑文的小支票。但随后他们说：哦，让我们去看看那个码头吧。那么他说的码头是什么？所以这座债券资助的公共工程仍然在那里。它依然屹立不倒。哦，嘿，是的。好吧。是的。而且它仍在调节水流，这可能是我整个故事中最喜欢的方面。哇。某种通过这张债券实现的现实生活中的人类壮举。是的。
And this kind of weird aspect of time travel where you are partially responsible for this thing that's nevertheless predates you. Right. When I went in 2015, I got to stand on the, on the pier, they called it, that, that, how this connection between me, between Yale and people who's working for a company that is the defendant of something that was established, no, four or five hundred years ago. I'm trying to wrap my head around just the value of this bond and the value of what they
还有这种奇怪的时空旅行感，你对这件先于你存在的事物负有一部分责任。没错。我在2015年去的时候，我得以站在他们称之为码头的地方，这种联系——我和耶鲁之间，以及那些为一家公司的辩护者工作的人之间，而这家公司是四五百年前建立的某事物的继承者。我试图去理解这张债券的价值以及他们支付金额的价值。所以，耶鲁买下它花了多少钱？显然，对任何纸币收藏家或集藏爱好者来说，这是一个极其罕见的物品。我不知道。但吉尔告诉我，他们是在拍卖会上以大约24,000美元的价格买下的。好吧。那蒂姆去那里的时候，他那张既大又小的支票拿到了多少钱？是的，没那么多。
pay out. So, Yale bought it for how much money? Obviously, it's an incredibly rare item for any scrupophilist or scrupophile. I don't know. But Gert told me that they got it at auction for roughly $24,000. Okay. And so how much did Tim get on his both big and tiny check when he went there? Yeah, not as much.
他们为每年支付的利息进行了12次拨付，而且是11年的逾期……所以加上12年的拖欠利息，总共达到了惊人的136欧元零几分。这就是永久债券的问题所在，通货膨胀真的会侵蚀掉这种债券的价值，荷兰盾已经不如从前了。确实如此。用那个再也买不到码头了。是的，先生。多亏了……吉尔不是。用那个再也买不到码头了。是的，先生。
They did 12 disbursements for every year worth of interest that was being paid out. And it was 11 year O 35 So with 12 years back interest that came out to a whopping 136 euros and change This is the thing about perpetual bond is that inflation really eats the value of a bond like this a careless gilder Just isn't what it used to be. It's not Can't buy a peer with that anymore. No sir. Thanks to be. Get's not. Can't buy a pier without anymore. No sir.
非常感谢。这也太棒了。罗曼，不客气。所以我现在和我们的作曲家肖恩·里亚尔在录音室里，你每年总是能给我带来一些精彩的音乐相关迷你故事。哦，谢谢你邀请我。那么今年你给我们带来了什么？好吧，你知道什么是音乐会音高吗？
Thanks so much. That's awesome too. Roman you're welcome. So I'm in the studio with Sean Rial, our composer, and you always bring me a delightful music-related many stories per year. Oh, thanks for having me. So what do you have for us this year? Okay, so do you know what concert pitch is?
我完全不知道什么是音乐会音高。好吧，这就是管弦乐队调音的依据，我们现在基本上有一个440赫兹的标准音高，这就好比，如果你想象一条正弦波，440赫兹意味着正弦波就像山峰和山谷，它在一秒钟内会上下起伏440次。好的。所以所有的乐器都调到这个音高，这样它们组合起来听上去才会好听。
I have no idea what concert pitch is. Okay, so it's what an orchestra will tune to, and we basically have like a standard pitch right now of 440 Hertz, which is like, if you think of a sine wave, 440 hertz means that the sine wave is like hills and valleys, it'll go up and down 440 times in a second. Okay. And so all the instruments are tuned to this pitch so that they all sound good together essentially.
一个乐器演奏的A音和其他乐器演奏的A音是同一个A音。完全正确。而440赫兹就是标准A音。好的。这是全世界所有管弦乐队的标准吗？还是会根据你所在的地方而有所不同？如果我们只谈论西方音乐，这主要是我对此进行研究的内容，就像有很多不同的调音传统一样，但在西方音乐中，直到很多流行音乐之类的，今天，它基本上都是440赫兹。他们是如何将这个确定为每个人都据此调音的数值的？我们走到这一步的历史其实非常混乱。
The A note that one instrument plays is the same A note that another instrument plays. Exactly. And 440 Hertz is concert A. Okay. Is this the standard for every orchestra all around the world or does it vary depending on where you are? If we're just talking about Western music, which is mostly what I've researched for this, like there are a lot of different tuning traditions, but in Western music, up to like a lot of pop music and stuff, today, it's like mostly 440 hertz. And how did they such a run that as being the value that everyone tunes to? It's actually a very messy history how we got here.
如果你倒回几百年前，如果你走遍欧洲不同的国家，你会听到截然不同的声音，关于不同管弦乐队的音高是什么。但是，只要房间里的所有乐器都是相同的调音，不同管弦乐队之间是否有相同的调音真的很重要吗？或者真的有人在意吗？曾经有一段时间，人们其实并不在意，而且音乐当时也没有传播得那么广，但一想到这个时期就会觉得非常着迷：如果你从一个国家旅行到另一个国家，你知道的，会引发很多骚动。
If you go back a few hundred years, if you go throughout different countries in Europe, you would be hearing wildly different things as far as what the pitch was for different orchestras. But as long as all the instruments in the room are the same tuning, does it really matter that between orchestras they have the same tuning or did anyone really care? There was a time where people didn't really care and music didn't really travel that much anyway, but it's really fascinating to think about this time where like if you were traveling from country to country, you know, to get a lot of uproar.
而且，如果你有很好的音准，你就能听出来。你能够听出，一些管弦乐队的音高调得很低，而另一些则调得很高。比如有的低至374赫兹，有的高达567赫兹，作为参考，我给你放一下那是什么声音。
And like, and had good pitch, you could like here. You'd be able to, you could tell that like the orchestra's were like somewhere tuned really low and somewhere tuned really high. Like some as low as like 374 hertz and some as high as 567 hertz, which just like for reference, let me play you what that is.
所以首先，我要给你播放440赫兹，这是我们今天的做法。好的。现在这是374赫兹。是的，真的差很多。是的，我的音准不是很好，这真的差很多。是的，我的音准不是很好，这真的非常不同。是的，它们都被认为是A音。哇，好吧。然后是最高的那个，567赫兹。哇。
So first, I'm gonna play you 440 which is what we do today. Okay. And now here's 374. Yes that's really different. Yeah I don't have very good pitch and that's really different. Yeah, I don't have a very good pitch and that's very different. Yeah, and those are both considered A. Wow, okay. And then the highest one, 567. Wow.
而这些本该是完全相同的音符。这就像是一整首音乐的参考点。这些数字的由来，是法国政府在19世纪对不同的管风琴进行的调查，管风琴曾经是许多管弦乐队的核心，它们只围绕着教堂的管风琴。为了调谐管风琴，这更像是建筑工程，
And those are all supposed to be the exact same note. That's like the reference point for an entire piece of music. And so where these numbers come from, is from this survey conducted by the French government in the 1800s of different pipe organs, which would like center pieces of a lot of orchestras, which are just centered around the church pipe organ. And in order to tune a pipe organ, like it's more like construction
而不是实际上的普通调音。所以直接根据管风琴来调音总是更有意义的。我明白，我明白，我明白。管风琴说那个A音是什么，那个房间的A音就是什么，因为重新调谐管风琴，可不像扭动小提琴上的一个小旋钮。不，这就像是进去锯东西、砂纸打磨……所以所有这些，你知道的，一些非标准的调音在不同的房间和音乐厅中得以延续，就是因为那里的管风琴。你知道的，是的，所以曾几何时管风琴是管弦乐队中最核心的部分。但随后欧洲开始发展。随着音乐会音乐越来越成为主流，越来越像是一场需要出席的活动，
than it is like actually just like regular tuning. So it's always made more sense to just Tune to the pipe organ. I see I see I see Whatever the a that the pipe organ says it is that is what the a is for that room because Retuning a pipe organ. It's not like twisting a little knob on a violin. No, it's like getting in and sawing stuff and sanding and So all these you know some unstandard tunings get perpetuated in different rooms and concert halls because of the
音乐厅开始建得越来越大。你知道的，你会有非常非常大的大厅，你可以把很多人塞进去，但他们无法真正适应声音是如何传播的。所以如果你坐在音乐厅的后排，你基本上只能听到低音，因为低音比高频音传得更远。为了弥补这一点，许多乐队指挥会把音高调高，于是他们让所有人都把一切都调高。我读到过一些故事，人们感到非常沮丧，因为他们的弦总是断，
pipe organ that is there. And you know, yeah, so there was a time when the pipe organ was like the most central part of the orchestra. But then stuff started to develop in Europe. And as like concert music became more of a thing, more of like an event to be attended.
歌手们因为过度用嗓而不得不去看医生，人们对此很不高兴。所以已经有了每个管风琴都不同的混乱，然后他们引入了音乐厅，然后又出现了关于如何变得更高的军备竞赛。这样你就能在音乐厅里被听得更清楚。然后情况变得更加混乱。因此，现在每个不同的音乐厅的音高都大不相同。偏差更大了。是的。但总体上一直在变高。特别是小提琴弦以及那种类型的弦乐器
Concert halls started being built bigger and bigger. You know, like you would have just like large, large halls, you could like put lots of people in it, but they couldn't really account for how sound travels. And so if you were sitting like in the back of a concert hall, you would mostly only hear the bass because bass notes just like travel farther than higher frequency notes. And so to compensate for this, a lot of orchestra leaders would tune higher, and so they would get everybody to just like move everything up. And there were just like stories that I was reading of like people being frustrated because like their strings were always breaking and And like singers were like having to go to the doctor from straining their voices and People weren't up or about this. So there's already the chaos of every pipe organ being different and then they introduce concert halls and then
能够调得更高，乐器制作商在制造更粗的弦以跟上音高逐渐上升的步伐。最终归结为歌手们说：你们必须停下来。你们必须停下来。我们必须停止这一切。你们不能再唱得更高了。事情发展到一定地步，法国政府甚至不得不颁布法令，规定管弦乐队的调音标准为435赫兹。好的。你刚才说440是现在的标准。所以435是……所以显然它发生了变化。
There's like this arms race for how to be higher. So you can be heard better in the concert halls. And then it gets more chaotic. And so every different concert hall is now pitched wildly different. It drifts even more. Yeah. But mostly consistently getting higher. And especially with violin strings and sort of like those kinds of stringed instruments
435是什么时候成为标准的？435于1859年在法国成为标准，但在后来的一段时间，即1919年，它被其他许多国家所采纳，这是因为第一次凡尔赛条约。所以就像那个作为第一次世界大战中德国投降标志的凡尔赛条约？是的，是的，那个结束了一次大战的条约。其中实际上有一个条款谈到了管弦乐队的调音。是的，第二部分第282条。
being able to be tuned higher, likering makers were making strings stronger in order to keep up with the pitch rising gradually. It came down to singers being like, you have to stop. You have to stop. We have to stop this. You can't sing any higher than this. And I got to a point where the French government actually had to decree that concert orchestras would tune at 435 Hertz. Okay. And so you said 440 was the standard now. So 435 is that so obviously it's shifted.
而且，他们对此是很认真的。哇，好吧。这里面有关于关税和标准化之类的内容。没错，这在某种程度上说得通。你试图创建一个统一的欧洲，你知道的，所以你会希望税收是公平的，进出口……所以你会希望税收是公平的，进出口……但你未必会期望法国的调音会成为凡尔赛条约中采纳的东西，但它确实在那里。然而他们确实这样做了。而美国当时调音标准是440。
When did 435 become the standard? So 435 became the standard in France in 1859, but then, while later, in 1919, it was adopted by a bunch of other nations, and that's because of the first Treaty of Versailles. So like the Treaty of Versailles that was the surrender of Germany during World War I? Yeah, yeah, the Treaty that ended World War I. That actually has a clause in it that talks about the tuning of orchestras. Yeah, Section II article 282.
所以我们实际上违反了凡尔赛条约。嗯，我们没有签署它。我们没有签署它。没错。但事实上，在这个特定实例中确实有一个国家违反了凡尔赛条约，至少是英国。条约中关于调音的表述是，你必须以15摄氏度室温下的音叉为依据，调到435赫兹。就像我认为英国的皇家爱乐乐团一样。我们当时觉得，嗯，我们的音乐厅稍微暖和一点。我们在20摄氏度左右。所以对我们来说调高一点是有道理的，因为温度实际上会把我们降到4.35，但实际上他们的最终音高大约是4.39。
Which, they took this seriously. Wow, okay. There's all this stuff about tariffs and like standardization things. Right, and that makes some sense. You're trying to create a unified Europe, you know, so you'd want taxes to be fair and important export, so you'd want taxes to be fair and important export, but you wouldn't necessarily expect French tuning to be the thing that is the thing that is adopted in the Treaty of Versailles, but there it is. And yet they did. And America at that point was tuning to 440.
好吧，随着一系列我并不觉得超级有趣的小插曲和细节，关于音乐会音高还有另一次类似思想碰撞的会议，在那之后音高被提高到了440。在那之后就是440。但令人惊奇的是，为了欧洲的和谐共存，将所有东西都调到相同的频率在文化上被认为如此重要。是的，当你考虑到乐器被制造出来是为了适应440赫兹（比如440A）的最佳状态时，这就很合乎情理了。但我对去隔壁小镇的想法还是抱有一点浪漫主义色彩，
So we actually violated the Treaty of Versailles. Well, we didn't sign it. We didn't sign it. That's right. But actually, one country that did violate the Treaty of Versailles in this particular instance, at least, was the United Kingdom. So the way that tuning is written in this convention that's in the treaty is that you have to tune to 435 hertz based on a tuning fork at a room temperature of 15 degrees Celsius. Like I think it was the royal Philharmonic in the UK. We're like, well our concert halls are a bit warmer. We're at about 20 degrees Celsius. So it makes sense for us to tune a little higher because the temperature would actually bring us like down to 4.35 but actually they were ending up at like 4.39
就像音乐听起来会有点不同。是的，那挺好的。就像你如果在布拉格听到亨德尔的《弥赛亚》之前，你就不算真正听过它。是的，正好。哦，那是我的另一个最爱。莫扎特实际上把所有的曲子都写在421赫兹。我想知道在关于莫扎特的电影里，他们是否真的……
okay with a bunch of like smaller instances and details that I didn't find super interesting there was another convention like meeting of the minds about concert pitch and there was raised to 440. 440 after that point. But that's amazing that it was considered so important culturally for the harmonious existence of Europe that everything be tuned to the same frequency. Yeah, it makes a lot of sense when you think about like instruments are built to like be optimal for a pitch of 440 hertz, like a 440A. But I feel a little romantic about the idea of just going to the town over,
哦，以正确的频率或者当时的频率完成了？他们似乎并没有。所以，我从来没有真正听过莫扎特的歌。确实如此。也许我们谁也没有听过。确实如此。这太酷了。让管弦乐队以原始调音数字化重制古典名曲，其实会是一个有趣的练习。你知道的，如果你去……如果听到其中是否存在真正的不同会很有趣，我不知道我能不能做到。我的音准不是很好。也许你会非常享受这个练习。是的，我想知道，我 wondering 是不是已经有人在那样做了。所以如果有人在那样做，请联系我们，告诉我们你们在做什么。这太棒了。
like the music's gonna sound a little different. Yeah, that's kind of nice. Like you haven't heard Handel's Messiah until you've heard it in Prague. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Oh, that was another one of my favorite things. Was that Mozart actually, like, wrote everything at 421. I was wondering if in the movie about Mozart, they had, like, actually...
好吧，酷。好的，谢谢你，约翰。谢谢你，罗曼。现在我和高级制片人凯蒂·明格尔在录音室里。嘿，罗曼。嘿，好久不见。我知道。你去哪了。所以，呃，你的故事是什么？嗯，我想我们应该从认识一个叫艾琳·韦尔茨尔的人开始。
Oh, done it at the right frequency or the contemporaneous frequency. They appeared to have not. So, I've never really heard a Mozart song. That's true. Maybe we none of us song. That's true. Maybe we none of us have. That's so cool. It would actually be kind of a fun exercise to have an orchestra digitally remaster the
喂？喂，请问是艾琳·韦尔茨尔太太吗？正是。所以艾琳和她的丈夫艾伦住在华盛顿特区一个叫做……所以艾琳和她的丈夫艾伦住在华盛顿特区一个叫做卡洛拉马（Calorama）的地方。这是一个非常高档的社区。杰夫·贝佐斯就住在那里。我明白。伊万卡·特朗普和贾里德·库什纳也住在那里，或者至少直到不久前还住在那里。我不确定他们现在是否还住在那里。还有一堆前总统，过去居住过的前总统，伍德罗·威尔逊，罗斯福，
classics in their original tuning. You know, like, if you so, if you so interesting to hear if there's a real difference, I don't know if I could. My pitch isn't so good. Maybe you would enjoy that exercise quite a bit. Yeah, I wonder, I wonder if there are people that are already doing that. So if anybody is doing that, please reach out to us and tell us about what you're doing. That's awesome.
奥巴马目前也住在那里。所以，是的，当你想到这个社区时，你会想到车队和特勤局的随从，这里确实有一些带院子的独立住宅。但同时也有很多联排别墅，一栋挨着一栋。但都是巨大的、多层的，你知道的。我们谈论的不是那种廉租公寓。但我想无论一个社区有多豪华，总会有那样的邻居，
Okay, cool. All right, well, thanks, John. Thank you, Roman. So I'm in the studio with Senior Producer, Katie Mingle. Hey, Roman. Hey, it's been a while. I know. Where you have. So, um, what's your story? Well, I think we should start out by meeting someone named Irene Wirtzel.
就是那种让人头疼的邻居。对。是的，所以艾琳隔壁就有一栋这样的房子。来吧，我其实让她来描述一下。嗯，这只是一栋非常早期的1900年代的房子，线条非常好，窗户很漂亮，从外面看起来很优雅。自从我们搬到这里以来，就一直没有人住在里面。我们谈论的是多久以前？
Hello Hello, is this Mrs. Irene Wirtzel? It is indeed. So Irene and her husband Alan live in an area in Washington, DC called So Irene and her husband, Alan, live in an area in Washington, DC called Calorama. It's a very fancy neighborhood. It's the neighborhood that Jeff Bezos lives in. I see. Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner live there, or at least they did until very recently. I'm not sure if they still do. A bunch of ex-presidents, former presidents of Lutthair, Woodrow Wilson, FDR,
那是自从1993年以来。哇，好吧。是的。时间相当长。是的，我想差不多有三十年了。我想差不多是……快到了。是的，这是一栋10,000平方英尺、五层的
The Obama's lived there currently. So, yeah, when you think of this neighborhood, think of motor cades and secret service, retinues, there are definitely some standalone homes with yards. But then there's also a lot of row houses, townhouses, right next to each other. But huge, multi-floor, you know. We're not talking about like tenements. But I guess no matter how fancy a neighborhood is, there's always going to be that neighbor
豪宅，所以这是一个巨大的空间，就这么空置了那么长时间。嗯哼，而且它还和艾琳与艾伦的房子连在一起。这是那些联排别墅之一，所以我认为那栋房子发生的事情实际上会影响到他们的地方。没错。如果一栋空置的物业有老鼠、白蚁或虫害问题，它实际上比其他情况给邻居带来更多麻烦，因为它们是连在一起的。没错。艾琳说，多年来，
who's just problematic. Right. Yeah, so Irene has this house right next to her. Here I'll actually let her describe it. Well, it's just a very early 1900s house with very good lines, nice windows, and it has an elegant look from the outside. And no one has lived in it since we've been here. And how long were we talking about?
出现过诸如混凝土块腐烂、砖块掉落之类的情况，我猜那栋房子上的一个木制窗框不知怎么掉到了他们的露台上，然后还有老鼠和其他小访客之类的问题。他们一直开着窗户，除其他外，鸟儿飞进飞出房子，房子侧面的窗户总是开着的，所以我认为鸟儿在那里筑巢。所以，是的，她说有过一个短暂的时期，
That's since 1993. Whoa, okay. Yeah. It's substantial. Yes, like almost three decades, I think. I think it's like, I think that's. It's getting close. Yeah, this is a 10,000 square foot five floor
隔壁这栋房子某种程度上变成了一个嘈杂的、某种形式的合租房。但大多数时候，自1993年以来它一直是空的。所以与其说她有一个麻烦的邻居，不如说她根本没有邻居，而这成了一个问题。没错。是的。
Mansion, so it's a huge it's a huge space to just sit empty for that long Mm-hmm, and it's also connected to Irene and Alan's house It's one of these row houses and so I think what happens to that house can actually affect their place. Right. If a vacant property has rats or termites or a bug problem, like it actually causes more problems to the neighbors than otherwise, because they're connected. Right. And Irene says, over the years,
那为什么它空置了这么久？这就是问题所在。与其说她根本没有邻居，不如说这成了一个问题。没错。是的。那为什么它空置了这么久？这就是问题所在。就是这样。这就是我们来这里的目的。好吧。答案是，这栋房子属于华盛顿特区一类特殊的房产，即外交房产。
there's been stuff like decaying pieces of concrete, bricks falling off, I guess a wooden window frame from that house dropped on to their patio somehow and then there have been things like rats and other little visitors. They kept the windows open and among other things birds flew in and out of the house, on the side of the house, the window was always open and so I think birds were building nest in there. So yeah, she said there was one brief period
比如有腐烂的混凝土块、掉落的砖块，我猜还有一个木制窗框不知怎么掉到了他们的露台上，然后还有老鼠和其他小动物。他们一直开着窗户，除其他外，鸟儿飞进飞出房子，在房子的侧面，窗户总是开着的，所以我想鸟儿在那里筑巢。所以是的，她说曾有过一段短暂的时期
where this house next door was kind of a noisy, rooming house of some sort. But mostly it's been empty since 1993. So it's not so much that she has like a problematic neighbor so that she just has no neighbor at all. And it's a problem. Right. Yeah.
隔壁这栋房子曾一度是那种吵闹的合租房。但自1993年以来，它大部分时间都是空置的。所以与其说她有一个问题邻居，不如说她根本没有邻居。这确实是个问题。对的。是的。
So why has it been so empty for so long? That is the question. as she just has no neighbor at all and it's a problem. Right. Yeah. So why has it been so empty for so long? That is the question. That's it. That's what we're here for. Okay. And the answer is that this house falls into this special category of property in DC, which is diplomatic property.
那么为什么它空置了这么久？这就是问题所在。与其说她根本没有邻居，不如说这本身就是个问题。对的。是的。那么为什么它空置了这么久？这就是问题所在。就是这样。这就是我们来这里的目的。好的。答案是，这栋房子属于华盛顿特区一类特殊的房产，即外交房产。
It's a very, it's like very DC problem. Yeah. One of my favorite things to do in DC is to go to the embassy row and spot all the flags. That's like my favorite thing to do. So what country owns this? Of course that's what I'm going to do. It's fun. But what country owns this property?
这是一个非常、非常具有华盛顿特区特色的小问题。是的。我在华盛顿特区最喜欢做的事情之一，就是去使馆街寻找所有的国旗。这简直是我最喜欢做的事。所以哪个国家拥有这个？我当然会这么做。这很有趣。但究竟是哪个国家拥有这栋房产呢？
This house is actually owned by the government of Argentina. It's not the embassy per se. It's a building that the government of Argentina. It's not the embassy per se. It's a building that the government owned. I'm not quite sure why. Maybe initially they would have people stay in this house when they came to town to do embassy business. I think it's possible that people who worked at the embassy may have lived there at some point. And DC has about 530 of these diplomatic properties like embassies and kind of additional houses and they're not all falling apart like this but there's definitely several buildings that are in pretty rough shape. They're
这栋房子其实归阿根廷政府所有。它本身并不是大使馆。这是阿根廷政府拥有的一栋建筑。它本身并不是大使馆。这是一栋政府拥有的建筑。我不太确定原因是什么。也许最初当人们来镇上处理大使馆业务时，会安排他们住在这栋房子里。我认为，曾在大使馆工作的人在某个时候也可能在那里住过。华盛顿特区大约有530处这种像大使馆以及类似附加房屋的外交房产，它们并不都像这样破败不堪，但确实有几栋建筑状况相当糟糕。它们
common enough that they're like YouTube videos that you can watch of people exploring them. So here let me put one of these on. All right, guys, so we're at an abandoned embassy. We already made it inside. First of all, this guy should have a second career as like ASMR video guy. Yeah. A lot of had this season stuff, even abandoned, just due to financial issues and then relations between the countries and other stuff like that. But this one's been abandoned.
非常普遍，甚至有你可以在网上观看的人们探索它们的YouTube视频。所以，我来播放其中一个。好了，各位，我们现在在一个废弃的大使馆里。我们已经进来了。首先，这家伙应该去兼职做ASMR视频博主。是的。很多这种由于财务问题以及国家之间关系等原因而废弃的东西，即使废弃了也是如此。但这座已经被废弃了。
There's one part where they're in the bathroom and they're kind of like, this is a bit day. This is what people in other countries used to watch their butts, you know? Like these guys don't know a ton about other cultures. Other cultures, necessarily. Like they're just, they're just doing YouTube stuff, trying to get some views. It's sort of not ideal to have all these empty mansions
其中有一段是他们身处浴室，然后他们有点像在说，这是个坐浴盆。这就是其他国家的人用来洗屁股的东西，你知道吗？就像这些家伙对其他文化并不是太了解。不一定了解其他文化。就像他们只是在做YouTube内容，试图获取一些点击量。让所有这些空置的豪宅
that only like law-breaking YouTubers are using, but it's actually really complicated and difficult to get anyone to do anything about these buildings. They aren't actually considered to be foreign soil. There's sort of a misconception out there that they are foreign soil, but they do have a bunch of special privileges. For example, the police couldn't get a warrant to search foreign embassy. And they're exempt from, I think, most, if not all taxes. And they don't have to build by code. Like, they're encouraged to. But like, they don't have to. I'm not really sure if I'm not really sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I'm not sure if I can call in the cops, clean it up, throw a fence around it, if necessary, seize it for unpaid taxes. He says, I have a lot of tools in my toolbox,
只有那些违法的YouTube博主在使用，这当然不是什么理想的情况，但实际上要让任何人对这些建筑采取行动是非常复杂且困难的。它们其实并不被视为外国领土。外界有一种误解，认为它们是外国领土，但它们确实拥有许多特权。例如，警察无法获得搜查外国大使馆的搜查令。而且它们免缴我认为绝大多数甚至全部税款。它们也不必按建筑规范建造。虽然鼓励它们这么做。但它们其实不必这样做。我不太确定我是否可以叫来警察，清理它，在周围拉起栅栏，如果有必要的话，因拖欠税款而查封它。他说，我的工具箱里有很多工具，
but I don't have those tools available to me if it's a diplomatic property. One thing that makes these properties interesting and maybe also a little harder to address is how different each one is. If you think about your neighbors kind of having issues or your neighbors potentially having baggage, behind each of these properties is basically the story of entire countries in political upheaval.
但如果这是一处外交财产，我就无法使用这些工具。让这些房产变得有趣、或许也更难处理的一个原因，是每一处房产都各不相同。如果你想到你的邻居们可能会有些问题，或者你的邻居们潜在地有些包袱，那么在每一处房产的背后，基本上都是整个国家陷入政治动荡的故事。
So let's take you to Yugoslavia. What is something that a country? Right. But they have a property? Yeah. Oh, God. They don't anymore, actually. But they did. And for quite a while, they had this house in 2006, all their diplomatic properties were divided among the six succeeding countries. And this house that they owned in DC was turned over to Bosnia.
所以让我们带你了解南斯拉夫。一个国家怎么会有……对。但他们有一处房产？是的。哦，天哪。其实他们现在没有了。但他们曾经有过。而且有相当长的一段时间，他们拥有这栋房子，在2006年，他们所有的外交房产都被平分给了六个继承国。而这栋他们在华盛顿特区拥有的房子则移交给了波斯尼亚。
You know, the deed was like never transferred. And then in 2008, someone at the Bosnia Embassy was quoted saying that they didn't even know who had the key. I guess they eventually found it because they did finally sell the house in 2015 for $650,000. But it had been vacant for like three decades. So it was in terrible shape. There was a tree growing through the garage. There was mold everywhere. And I think the owners basically gutted it and started over. So in response to a lot of different neighbors complaining about a lot of different properties, the State Department issued a response saying saying, you know, basically our hands are tied because of this Vienna Convention. And the only recourse we really have is to remove diplomatic status from these properties,
你知道，房契似乎从未被转移过。然后在2008年，波斯尼亚大使馆的一位官员曾表示，他们甚至不知道谁有钥匙。我猜他们最终还是找到了，因为他们在2015年终于以65万美元的价格把房子卖掉了。但它已经空置了大约三十年。所以它的状况糟糕透顶。车库里甚至长出了一棵树。到处都是霉菌。我想业主基本上把它内部砸光重来了。因此，为了回应许多不同邻居对许多不同房产的抱怨，国务院发表了一份声明，基本上说我们的手被绑住了，因为这个《维也纳公约》，
in which case they become subject to the same like property taxes as everyone else. And sometimes that motivates them to sell. So, what don't they do that? What's the problem with that? I think they do sometimes do that, but I think they're pretty hesitant to do it because they want to maintain good relations with these countries, and these properties, I think, are probably kind of low on their list of concerns overall. And actually, in the case of the Argentinian place right next to Irene and Alan, they actually did remove diplomatic status from that property and it didn't seem to make a big difference.
在这种情况下，它们将和所有人一样需要缴纳房产税。有时这会促使他们出售。那么，他们为什么不这么做呢？这有什么问题吗？我想他们有时确实会这样做，但我认为他们对此相当犹豫，因为他们希望与这些国家保持良好关系，而且总体而言，这些房产在他们的关切列表中可能排名相当靠前。事实上，就在伊琳和艾伦隔壁的那处阿根廷房产，他们确实取消了该房产的外交地位，但这似乎并没有产生多大影响。
Huh, why not? I mean, just politics again, like I believe Argentina's ambassador told the word sales that the country would actually gladly be free of the property and the tax burden of it, but because of a loan that the country had defaulted on in 2001, they couldn't just like freely sell their assets. So I don't know if that's still the case for Argentina. I did not reach out to the country of Argentina for comment, but they still haven't sold it. And Irene told me that about six months ago they saw for sales sign go up in the yard and they got really excited, but it came down a few days later and
啊，为什么不呢？我的意思是，这依然是政治问题，比如我相信阿根廷大使曾告诉世界新闻销售网，该国其实很乐意摆脱这处房产及其带来的税收负担，但由于该国在2001年发生过债务违约的贷款，他们无法像那样自由地变卖资产。所以我不知道阿根廷现在是否还是这种情况。我没有就此联系阿根廷国家置评，但他们仍然没有把它卖掉。伊琳告诉我，大约六个月前，他们看到院子里挂出了“待售”的牌子，他们感到非常兴奋，但几天后牌子就摘下来了，
she thinks maybe they just changed their mind. That's too bad. Yeah. That's so cool. I'd never have thought about that at all before when I was looking at flags and embassy roads. So another thing to consider. Yeah. And thanks to a writer at the Washington Post named Jenna Portinoi who wrote the article, where I first read about this, also thanks to Abby Madden, who works with us on the show, and helped me with a lot of this research. Cool. Alright, thanks everybody. We have one more story about secret nuclear families and how they were hidden from foreign spies and even the post office after this.
她觉得可能是他们又改变主意了。那太糟糕了。是的。真是太酷了。当我看着国旗和使馆街时，我以前从来没有想过这些。所以这是另一个需要考虑的问题。是的。感谢《华盛顿邮报》一位名叫珍娜·波蒂诺伊的作家，她写了这篇文章，我也就是在那里第一次读到这件事；还要感谢与我们一起制作节目的艾比·马登，她在这项研究中帮了我很多忙。太酷了。好的，谢谢大家。接下来我们还有一个关于秘密核家庭的故事，以及他们是如何在冷战期间对外國间谍甚至邮局隐瞒的。
Okay, so I'm here with Delaney Hall and so what is your mini story? So I'll start by telling you about these home movies that I recently came across on YouTube that have kind of been haunting me. They're from the 1940s, so they don't have any sound. I'll just have to describe them to you. Imagine early color films, so the colors are kind of muted and washed out. And the films show footage of these young people, like in their 20s and 30s, they're riding horses through the mountains of New Mexico. They're skiing, they're playing tennis. There's
好的，我和德兰妮·霍尔在这里，那么你的微型故事是什么？所以我要先讲讲我最近在YouTube上偶然发现的一些家庭录像，它们一直萦绕在我心头。它们是20世纪40年代的，所以没有任何声音。我只能向你们描述一下。想象一下早期的彩色电影，所以颜色有点柔和而且褪色。这些电影展示了这些年轻人的镜头，大约20多岁和30多岁，他们正骑着马穿过新墨西哥州的群山。他们在滑雪，在打网球。有一个
one movie where it looks like they're having a party at a lake, so they're all embading suits and there's this one woman carrying a 12 pack of cores on her shoulder. And others doing that like funny walk and flippers down to the edge of the water. That doesn't sound especially haunting. That sounds real pleasant. I know. I know. They are like, they're totally normal home movies, but they're haunting once you understand the context, which is these were movies filmed by a physicist named Hugh Bradner back in the 1940s, at a place that was then known by a secret code name,
电影里看起来他们正在湖边举行派对，所以他们都穿着泳衣，有一个女人肩膀上扛着一箱12罐的库尔斯啤酒。还有人穿着脚蹼以那种滑稽的步伐走到水边。这听起来并不怎么令人萦绕心头。这听起来非常愉快。我知道。我知道。它们就像是完全正常的家庭录像，但一旦你理解了背景，它们就变得挥之不去——这些录像是20世纪40年代一位名叫休·布拉德纳的物理学家在一个当时被称为秘密代号的地方拍摄的，
Project Y, or Site Y. Today it's Los Alamos, and so all of these seemingly carefree young people, they weren't just having a great time in, you know, beautiful Northern New Mexico. They were helping to build the first atomic bomb. Right, oh, that adds a lot of context. The heavy stuff is going on in the background of that.
Y计划或Y基地。如今它是洛斯阿拉莫斯，所以所有这些看似无忧无虑的年轻人，他们不仅仅是在风景优美的新墨西哥州北部玩得开心。他们还在协助制造第一颗原子弹。没错，哦，这增加了大量的背景信息。沉重的事情正在这一切的背景下发生。
Yeah, and it's sort of the contrast of them having fun, hanging out, and then knowing what they were doing during their working lives. And, you know, they were helping to build this weapon of enormous power and destruction. It's going to completely transform the world, the geopolitics of the world. But they're also just, you know, young people living their lives. There were a lot of young people here. The average age was 29. The most common age was 27.
是的，这是一种对比，他们一边玩耍、闲逛，一边又清楚自己在工作期间究竟在做些什么。而且，你知道的，他们正在协助制造这种拥有巨大威力和破坏力的武器。它将彻底改变世界，改变世界的地缘政治。但他们同时也是，你知道的，过着自己生活的年轻人。这里有很多年轻人。平均年龄是29岁。最普遍的年龄是27岁。
So you had a lot of young single people here. There were a lot of young couples. So this is Alan Carr. And he is the senior historian at Los Alamos National Lab. And he says the fact that there were all these young people working together on the Manhattan Project at Los Alamos actually presented some surprising security challenges. Because for one thing, some of them, it turns out, were like, hooking up and getting married and having babies out there on this top secret military campus, which was not even supposed to be a place on the map.
所以这里有很多年轻的单身人士。有很多年轻夫妇。这位是艾伦·卡尔。他是洛斯阿拉莫斯国家实验室的高级历史学家。他说，曼哈顿计划期间，所有这些年轻人一起在洛斯阿拉莫斯工作这一事实，实际上带来了一些令人惊讶的安全挑战。因为一方面，事实证明，他们中的一些人，比如在这个绝密的军事园区里谈恋爱、结婚并生孩子，而这里甚至不应该是一个存在于地图上的地方。
All of a sudden you went from a locale in New Mexico where no children were ever born hardly. To all of a sudden there's eight births a month. That looks awfully suspicious if you're doing the paperwork down in Santa Bay. Why are all these kids being born in Los Alamos? I don't even know what Los Alamos is. So now we think of Los Alamos as this place where the bomb was made. But at the time was Los Alamos even like a place that would have couples and babies? Right. No. Back then it wouldn't have been. Yeah, and that's an important point. And so to understand why this would have been suspicious, let's backtrack. And I'll explain
突然之间，你从一个几乎从来没有新生儿降生的新墨西哥州地方，变成了突然每个月有八个新生儿出生。如果你在圣达菲做文书工作，这看起来可疑极了。为什么所有这些孩子都出生在洛斯阿拉莫斯？我甚至不知道洛斯阿拉莫斯是什么。所以现在我们认为洛斯阿拉莫斯是制造炸弹的地方。但在当时，洛斯阿拉莫斯甚至是一个会有夫妇和婴儿的地方吗？对。没有。那时候根本不会有。是的，这是一个重点。为了解为什么这会令人怀疑，让我们回顾一下。我来解释一下
how the government even chose Los Alamos as the site for bomb development and what it was like before it became project-wide. So what happened is in 1942 the military decides they need a central laboratory in an isolated place where they can design, build and test nuclear weapons. Where do you put a place that does those types of things? This was arguably history's biggest super secret project. And so they decide there's some very important criteria for this place. It needs to be remote for safety reasons. You know, they want to keep the scientists who are working on the project away from other people. They do not want them accidentally blabbing about what they're doing.
政府究竟是如何选择洛斯阿拉莫斯作为炸弹研发基地的，以及它在成为Y计划之前是什么样子的。事情是这样的，1942年，军方决定他们需要在偏远地区建立一个中央实验室，在那里他们可以设计、建造和测试核武器。你把一个做这种类型事情的地方放在哪里？这可以说是历史上最大的绝密项目。因此他们决定，这个地方有一些非常重要的标准。出于安全原因，它需要偏远。你知道，他们希望将从事该项目的科学家与其他人群隔离开来。他们绝对不希望这些人不小心说漏嘴他们在做什么。
Yeah, that makes sense too. And they also want it to be near a real hub so that they can ship all the stuff they need there, cycle a trance, and whatnot. And then finally, they want it to be at least 200 miles from any international boundaries. You know, maybe they watch, you know, these old movies where a saboteur gets off a submarine and runs in and sabotages the factory it blows up. We want the saboteur to have to run a long, long way, right?
是的，这也说得通。他们还希望它靠近一个真正的交通枢纽，这样他们就可以把所需的所有东西运到那里，通过火车周转，诸如此类。最后，他们希望它距离任何国际边界至少200 miles（约321公里）。你知道，也许他们看过，你知道的，那些老电影，一个破坏分子从潜水艇上下来，跑进来破坏了工厂并把它炸毁了。我们希望破坏分子不得不跑很长很长的路，对吧？
That's a good point. Yeah. So at this point, and again, this is 1942, Robert Oppenheimer has been selected as the head of Project Y. And he had spent a lot of his time in his youth in Northern New Mexico, which is remote and meets, you know, most of the other criteria. So they start looking around the area and pretty soon they settled on what's now known as Los Alamos, which is about 45 minutes northwest of Santa Fe.
这倒是个好观点。是的。所以在这个时候，再次说明这是1942年，罗伯特·奥本海默被选为Y计划的负责人。他年轻时大部分时间都在新墨西哥州北部度过，那里很偏远，并且符合（你知道的）大部分其他标准。所以他们开始在该地区四处查看，很快他们就选定了现在被称为洛斯阿拉莫斯的这个地方，它位于圣达菲西北方向大约45分钟车程的地方。
Yeah, so what was Los Alamos, like really like back then? Like how would people think of Los Alamos back then? Back then it wasn't even a town. There was, yeah, there was this rustic boys school there called the Los Alamos Ranch School. And that was about it. So the government just bought the school. They went about setting up this state of the art lab
是的，那么洛斯阿拉莫斯当时到底是什么样的？人们在当时会怎么看待洛斯阿拉莫斯？在那时，它甚至算不上一个镇。那里，是的，那里有一所古朴的男子学校，叫做洛斯阿拉莫斯牧场学校。基本上就只有这些。于是政府买下了这所学校。他们着手建立这个最先进的实验室，
on the top of this very isolated remote mesa. Okay, that sounds like hard. That sounds like logistically very difficult to do. And then especially in 1942. Yeah, it was kind of a logistical nightmare. Like, the whole location was served by this one little road that snaked up a huge cliff. And they were shipping in massive pieces of equipment, pipes for one thing, because Alan Carr told me there wasn't a reliable water supply, and there also wasn't any electricity. And so the original engineers who built the town acquired a large generator in Texas. They had it shipped to Santa Fe by train, put it on a truck, and
在这个非常孤立偏远的平顶山顶部。好吧，听起来这很难。从后勤角度来看，这做起来非常困难。而且特别是在1942年。是的，这简直是一场后勤噩梦。整个地点只有一条小路提供服务，这条路蜿蜒爬上一处巨大的悬崖。他们运送着大量的重型设备，比如管道，因为艾伦·卡尔告诉我，那里没有可靠的供水，也没有任何电力。因此，建造小镇的最初工程师们在德克萨斯州采购了一台大型发电机。他们用火车将其运到圣达菲，装上卡车，然后
drove it up the hill, and as they were, it fell off the truck. It broke, it cracked, and they welded it back together and managed to get it up the hill. And so in those opening months of 1943, the real heroes were the construction workers. So like listening to all the things that they had to do, it doesn't sound like you could keep Los Alamos a secret for very long. Like if you're shipping gigantic generators and there's these trucks on the highway, I mean how do you keep that all secret? Right. Yeah, it's kind of mind-boggling. So for secrecy, the main thing they did
把它开上山，但在他们行驶的过程中，它从卡车上掉了下来。它坏了，裂开了，然后他们把它焊接好，设法把它拉上了山。所以在1943那开局的几个月里，真正的英雄是建筑工人们。所以听了他们不得不做所有这些事情之后，听起来你似乎无法将洛斯阿拉莫斯作为一个秘密保守太久。如果你在运送巨大的发电机，公路上还有这些卡车，我的意思是，你怎么能把这一切都保密呢？对。是的，这有点令人匪夷所思。所以为了保密，他们做的主 要事情是
is that the people who worked on the project weren't necessarily told what they were going to be doing until they agreed to join the project. So they'd be told something vague, like, you'll be doing important work for the war effort. It might help to bring the war to an end, but it was really only after you arrived in Los Alamos that you would learn the details.
参与该项目的人在他们同意加入项目之前，并不一定会被告知他们将要做什么。所以他们会被告知一些模糊的事情，比如，你将为战争努力做重要的工作。这可能有助于结束战争，但实际上只有当你到达洛斯阿拉莫斯之后，你才会了解到细节。
There was also a fence around the whole town so that people couldn't just wander in. And then there was the male. So all the male was censored, obviously, so that no one would accidentally write a friend and say what they were doing. Right. That totally makes sense.
整个小镇周围还有一道栅栏，这样人们就不会随便乱闯进来。还有邮件。因此，所有的邮件显然都经过了审查，这样就不会有人不小心写信给朋友并说出他们在做什么。对，完全说得通。
I mean, I'm surprised they even had male. I mean, how could you have male trucks coming in and out of Los Alamos? I mean, that seems like a huge security risk in and of itself. Right. It would have been. And so according to Alan, there were not male tricks coming in and out of Los Alamos. All the male was actually delivered to Santa Fe and it was delivered to just two main PO boxes that served the entire project why. So there was PO Box 1663, which was for the civilians,
我的意思是，我很惊讶他们甚至还有邮件。我的意思是，你怎么能让运送邮件的卡车进出洛斯阿拉莫斯呢？我的意思是，这本身似乎就是一个巨大的安全风险。对。确实如此。所以根据艾伦的说法，并没有邮政卡车进出洛斯阿拉莫斯。所有的邮件实际上都是运送到圣达菲的，并且只投递到为整个Y计划服务的两个主要邮政信箱。所以有一个1663号信箱，是给平民准备的，
because all the scientists working on the project were civilians. And then there was PO Box 1539 for the military. So that meant that all the male coming to the area just went to one place that was far from the actual town. And then it would likely have been trucked up by the military. So if there are two PO boxes for the entire community, is that like a people wrote to a thousand people per PO box basically? Yeah, yeah, okay. So the number, the number of civilians working at Los Alamos was in the thousands. It would have been in the low thousands. I would guess people receiving mail at PO box 1663, probably somewhere between four and 5,000. So a lot of mail.
因为所有在项目上工作的科学家都是平民。然后还有一个1539号信箱是给军方准备的。这意味着所有运往该地区的邮件都只会去到一个距离实际城镇很远的地方。然后它很可能会由军方用卡车运送上去。如果整个社区只有两个邮政信箱，那是不是就像人们基本上是写信给每个邮政信箱一千个人？是的，是的，好吧。所以，在洛斯阿拉莫斯工作的平民人数是以千计的。应该在低位千数。我猜在1663号邮政信箱接收邮件的人，大概在四千到五千之间。所以有大量的邮件。
And okay, the fascinating thing is that this whole PO Box thing actually connects back to the Los Alamos baby boom that we were talking about at the beginning. Okay, that was that. So as Alan was saying, there were all these young people working in Los Alamos back in the 1940s. The scientists and engineers who worked on the bomb, they were civilians, which meant the military could not boss them around as easily or control their behavior in the same way they could with people who were enlisted.
好了，最吸引人的地方在于，这个整个邮政信箱的事情实际上与我们在开头谈到的洛斯阿拉莫斯婴儿潮联系在了一起。好的，就是那个。正如艾伦所说，在20世纪40年代，有这么多的年轻人在洛斯阿拉莫斯工作。那些从事炸弹研究的科学家和工程师都是平民，这意味着军方无法像对待应征入伍人员那样，轻易地对他们发号施令或以同样的方式控制他们的行为。
It's easier to control people in uniform than civilians. If you've got a bunch of people in uniforms here working, one thing that they're not doing is getting married and having children. But the civilian scientists, that's exactly what they were doing. A lot of them were young. They're basically partying when they weren't working as I've seen in those home movies they shot. And they were also having babies, which was a total headache for the military. Oppenheimer's boss was the general named General Leslie Groves, and he didn't like all these kids being born, you know, because, well, first of all, you have to try and keep
控制穿制服的人比控制平民要容易。如果你这里有一群穿制服的人在工作，他们不做的一件事就是结婚生子。但那些平民科学家，这正是他们在做的事情。他们中的许多人很年轻。正如我在他们拍摄的那些家庭录像中看到的那样，他们在不工作的时候基本就是在开派对。而且他们还在生孩子，这对军方来说绝对是个头痛的问题。奥本海默的上司是一位名叫莱斯利·格罗夫斯（Leslie Groves）的将军，他不希望所有的这些孩子出生，你知道的，因为，好吧，首先，你必须努力保守秘密。
it secret. You have to put a maternity ward in the hospital. You have to have a school district. All these things he didn't want to have to worry about. So he ordered Oppenheimer to tell the staff to stop having kids. So that went over well. Yeah. Yeah, it did.
你必须在医院里设立一个产科病房。你必须建立一个学区。所有这些都是他不想去操心的事情。所以他下令奥本海默告诉员工们不要再生孩子了。这下事情进展得很顺利。是的。是的，确实如此。
Actually, as I'm sure you can imagine, did not go over well. Especially considering that the director's wife, Kitty, was pregnant at the time. So I don't think that that order was carried out. So how did they manage to keep all these, you know, new Los Alamos babies under wraps? So the main way was that they did not list
实际上，正如你所能想象的那样，事情并没有进展顺利。特别是考虑到主任的妻子基蒂（Kitty）当时正怀着孕。所以我认为这个命令并没有得到执行。那么他们是如何设法把所有这些（你知道的）洛斯阿拉莫斯新生儿保密的呢？所以主要的办法是他们没有列出
the place of birth on the birth certificates. They couldn't put Los Alamos because Los Alamos didn't really exist in the official record. It was totally Tom's secret. They couldn't put Project Y because that would also be weird. And so even though these babies were born at the hospital in Los Alamos, their birth certificate just said PO Box 1663. If it says PO Box 1663, that keeps that a lot more secret. Although it also seems like you'd be like, what are these babies born at a PO Box? That's right. But at least the PO Box doesn't give you a location. And that's what they were trying
出生证明上的出生地点。他们不能写洛斯阿拉莫斯，因为在官方记录中洛斯阿拉莫斯并不真正存在。这完全是绝密的。他们不能写Y计划，因为那也会很奇怪。因此，尽管这些婴儿出生在洛斯阿拉莫斯的医院里，但他们的出生证明上只写着：1663号邮政信箱。如果上面写着1663号邮政信箱，这能让保密工作做得更好。尽管这也让人觉得，这些婴儿是在一个邮政信箱出生的吗？没错。但至少邮政信箱没有给出具体位置。而这正是他们试图
to keep secret. So any idea is like how many kids were actually born and and and have the PO Box listed as their place of birth? Alan, guess maybe a hundred or a hundred and fifty kids. He has actually seen some of the birth certificates before. A weird side effect of history. Well, cool. Well, thank you so much Delaney. Appreciate it. Yeah, thank you. As of the beginning of 2020, 99% invisible is Avery Truffleman, Katie Mangle, Kurt Colstad, Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker, Chris Barubey,
保持秘密的地方。所以有没有什么想法，究竟有多少孩子出生，并且以邮政信箱作为他们的出生地登记呢？艾伦猜测大约有一百或一百五十个孩子。他实际上以前看过一些出生证明。历史的一个奇怪副作用。好吧，太棒了。好吧，非常感谢德兰妮。谢谢你。是的，谢谢。截至2020年初，“99%无形”由艾弗里·特鲁弗曼（Avery Truffleman）、凯蒂·曼格（Katie Mangle）、库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）、德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、谢里·菲塞夫（Sheree Fusef）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Barubey），
and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fursuitly independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc.
以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）组成。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心无线电街。我们是PRX旗下“无线电乌托邦”（Radio Topia）的创始成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的绝对独立的集体。欢迎在 radiotopia.fm 发现、收听并支持他们所有人。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我 @Roman Mars，以及节目 @99PI Org。
We're on Instagram and read it too. But the real 99PI HQ is our lovely, lovely website, at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。但真正的99PI总部是我们可爱至极的网站：99PI.org。PRX旗下的无线电乌托邦。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。